[Music]
hi i'm bradley and this is little light
studios and you're watching i've got a
question today's question is what is
predictive programming
it was oscar wilde who famously wrote
life imitates art far more than art
imitates life
so what happens when society follows
what they see in today's technologically
advanced art movies and music
what and who decides what form of art
are being produced to affect the minds
with some strange ideas
today we are answering all those
questions about predictive programming
so what is predictive programming
it's a theory developed by a philosopher
named alan watt who said that predictive
programming is a subtle form of
psychological conditioning
provided by the media to acquaint the
public with planned societal changes to
be implemented by our leaders if and
when these changes are put through the
public will already be familiarized with
them and will accept them as natural
progressions thus lessening the possible
public resistance and commotion while
this theory is popular among well-known
conspiracy websites and personalities
the reality is that the truth is far
more sinister than that the majority of
predictive programming is not planned by
humans
the originator is the devil
the organized dissension of society
through art comes from a far more
coordinated spiritual realm
the oldest form of this desensitization
comes from the devil himself when he
attempted to confuse and distract people
from the bible prophecies foretelling
the coming of the savior jesus christ
before jesus was born the egyptian god
horus the greek god dionysus the indian
god krishna and the persian god mithra
all claim to be fulfilling the
prophecies
with similar traits of jesus christ
all these stories falsely claim to be
born of a virgin
to have disciples to be dead and to be
resurrected and many more
this desensitized people to the idea of
this fulfillment happening from
scripture
as there are already so many claiming
these prophecies
in the same manner just before jesus was
born the devil moved to create false
messiahs
these events and more desensitized the
religious leaders and confused people
slowing down the progress of the gospel
although not all media may contain
predictive programming that form of
propaganda that we experience today is
both human created and spiritually
created by influencing the writers of
popular tv shows and movies
this form of media is especially
effective at subtly introducing new
ideas and developing our reactions to
future events
this media guides minds towards lower
passions and evil propensities
movies often call rule keeping archaic
and dangerous
alluding to god being like a machine or
robot
uplifting emotional desires and feelings
and downplaying the logic and rational
thought which allows us to determine
right and wrong so how do you mitigate
the effect of this propaganda in our
life
simply by distancing yourself from the
entertainment media and substituting it
with prayer and communication with god
it is inevitable that we will experience
this propaganda through subtle messages
we receive in music and video anywhere
from grocery store to the gas station
pump
but the danger comes in when we allow
our minds to subconsciously entertain
these ideas jesus knows that we each
live in a life full of danger
and when we abide in him his holy spirit
will guide and protect us keeping us on
the straight and narrow if we
continually choose to follow him
by excluding yourself from being
entertained by the entertainment history
you have effectively disabled an avenue
that satan has to your heart
opening new pathways for the holy spirit
to work on your character
proverbs 4 23 says keep your heart with
all diligence for out of it springs the
issues of life
in another version it says guard your
heart for everything you do flows from
it
thanks for watching if you have a
question leave it in the comments below
it means the world to us to hear from
you
and we try to answer every question that
comes in
don't forget to like subscribe to our
channel and to share it on your social
media platform
see you next time
[Music]
so
you